the utter destruction of ukraine is not
being seen by the people whose country
is causing it state television where
most russians get their information
presents vladimir putin's message a
military operation welcomed by
ukrainians and sanitized for russian
consumption
many russians don't want to know as
radio free europe discovered
i support putin says this woman i won't
look at these photos
this man insists no one is bombing keeve
i don't believe
it and those who do believe it and speak
out are quickly rounded up and jailed
but no amount of propaganda or
censorship can shield everyday russians
from the global backlash starting with
long lineups for cash and now seeing
major companies pulling up stakes some
300 businesses led by the tech industry
and payment systems are pausing
operations in russia from fast food and
fossil fuels to cars computers and
parkas one moscow resident who does not
want to be identified tells global news
it is depressing i think people are
starting to feel it fast food chains or
like clothes brand are leaving the
country which affects
citizens affects their own lives even
though they don't feel like they should
participate in it the closing of more
than 800 mcdonald's marks the end of an
opening to russia that was hoped would
democratize russia and it is the russian
people who will feel the isolation and
unemployment
brought about by vladimir putin's
invasion
he is sealing his country off completely
from the rest of the world because no
one in in the media right now because
it's controlled the russian government
will tell that truth to russian people
one teacher willing to talk publicly
tells global news an increasing number
of russians do not believe the
propaganda and must speak out the least
we can do is just to show the rest of
the world that well actually the
russians are not very
supportive of that war the question is
whether russian's own suffering and
setbacks will make president putin
change course or cause him to escalate
the russian attack on ukraine eric
sorensen global news toronto